I just learned there's a plant called
Baby Bum that looks like two tiny cheeks
peeking out of pants the succulent
endemic to the Western Cape in South
Africa has no medicinal or cultural uses
but it's very popular due to its
adorable gluteus maximus-like appearance
what's cool about the region where it's
found is that due to being surrounded by
mountains it gets very little rainfall
and has spawned hundreds of completely
unique succulents including a little bug
Vsauce one story down seven to go this
is mind blow this shape-shifting haptic
display for 3D designs is made from 100
soft robotic muscles that can activate
50 times per second designed by
engineers at the University of Colorado
Boulder and the Max Planck Institute for
intelligence systems it has multiple
functions each pixel is made up of an
actuator a magnetic sensor and a control
circuit it can create shapes respond to
human touch manipulate objects and
generate images so for instance a
magnetic wand can be used to draw
imagery it can display the estimated
mass of an object and it can move as
well as sort objects or it could just do
any combination of these tasks and they
hope to use this technology for future
applications in the gaming industry
medical field or even in manufacturing
such as handling toxic materials
microchip brain implants have restored
feeling and movement in a man living
with quadriplegia the double neural
bypass is a first of its kind clinical
trial performed by bioelectric medicine
researchers surgeons and engineers at
northwell Health's Feinstein institutes
for medical research the brain body and
spinal cord were linked together
electronically for the first time in a
paralyzed human to restore lasting
movement and sensation with the help of
AI and the long-term goal of This
research isn't limited to re-linking
these connections but the hope that one
day disease and injury could be treated
with our own nerves and without the need
for pharmaceuticals in science Takes
Time News 10 years ago I told you about
the bacteria killing wings of clanger
cicadas and now we understand how it
works using ORNL Summit supercomputer
they were able to model the
nanostructure of the Wings to understand
how the Nano pillars not only kill
bacteria but also clean the surface this
is extremely important because killing
the bacteria isn't enough if debris is
Left Behind it becomes a great
environment for more bacteria to absorb
on top of them but this nanopillar
structure continues to stress the
membrane after rupturing and the tension
builds until the bacteria is detached
this could be huge news for developing
antibacterial Coatings for use in the
medical field such as on devices like
catheters do you want to know how the
vsauce2 sauce messages made for years
I've been using story blocks the sponsor
of this video storyblocks is a stock
media subscription service for unlimited
downloads of royalty free video if
you're a Creator this is the way to go a
simple subscription a huge library of
video images sound effects music and
editing templates and it's all 100
royalty free forever with no
restrictions on where you distribute
your videos no more expensive
pay-per-clip pricing it's easy it's
excellent that's why I use storyblocks
to get started with unlimited downloads
at one set price go to storyblocks.com
vsauce2 or click the link down in the
description below storyblocks is awesome
a new algorithm has identified its first
potentially hazardous asteroid Rock
based bodies of every size are flying
around Earth some are just a few feet
wide and others are the size of the moon
but the verisi Rubin observatory in
Chile has developed the heliolink 3D
algorithm to identify the ones that
might pose a threat to us like 2022
sf289 sf289 is 600 feet long and
classified as a potentially hazardous
asteroid or PHA meaning that if threat
to Earth isn't imminent an 8.4 meter
mirror and 3200 megapixel camera tracks
phas twice per night to make sure they
stay in line because in the grand scheme
of space being 13 million miles away is
a little too close for comfort buddy we
can snag water with spider silk
condensing water in the air is usually a
highly energy intensive process but
spiders do it without even trying
researchers at China's Bayonne
University have designed artificial
microfibers with enough surface area to
attract droplets of water the same way
Dew forms on spider webs a series of
helical spindle grooves helps channel
the water achieving collection volumes
2114 times greater than simple
microfiber knots it's an efficient
passive collection method that lets
nature do the work for you so if you're
parched in the middle of the Sahara just
whip out your helical Groove spindle
knot microfiber blanket and start
chugging or get that eat pant Bart
Simpson on your lower back when you can
put a nano tattoo on an individual cell
researchers at John Hopkins University
have successfully tattooed an array of
wires on living cells to monitor their
health soft cells are a unique challenge
for adhering foreign elements because
living cells actually move the team's
bioprinting transfer strategy attached
precursors to Nano circuits onto rat
brains which they hope will pave the way
for tattooing sensors that can identify
problems in organs on a small scale
before there's a major problem so Kat
Von D is gonna have to up her game Into
Gold Nano patterns and alginate
hydrogels it turns out jellyfish have
been swimming around for half a billion
years for over three decades fossils
excavated from the Burgess Shale region
in the Canadian Rockies have been
sitting in the Royal Ontario Museum in
Toronto well recently somebody finally
took a look at him jellyfish start as
polyps on the ocean floor which
reproduce asexually then they evolve
into medusas that can swim around freely
an analysis of 182 fossil samples
discovered the oldest for gesso Medusa
phasma Forest ever seen clocking in over
50 million years older than the
horseshoe crab but a couple hundred
million years younger than the boring
sea sponge some of the Burgess Shale
fossils are so well preserved that they
show what an animal's last meal was so
just know that 500 million years from
now alien archaeologists are gonna judge
you for eating ham and cheese Hot
Pockets the night before you died just
something to think about and now
introducing the RCA XL 100 the TV that
thinks in color from 1975.
it means RCA's most Vivid color
most automatic systems and for
reliability the most tested TV in RCA
history
the new RCA xl100 color track system
thinks in color